ce n'est pas un secret de rats je suis
déjà à écouter aujourd'hui je vous
parlais un peu de trucs d'horreur en
général mais sans faire un thread
horreur même si vous savez je suis très
friand tout comme vous de toutes ces
histoires ory
je sais pas si c'est le fait d'avoir
joué à des jeux d'horreur pendant toutes
ces années ou si c'est juste que j'ai
toujours qui fait ça en moi je sais pas
comment s'est déclenchée mais j'adore
l'horreur c'est un secret pour personne
et plus particulièrement bien évidemment
les films d'horreur en fait je trouve ça
hyper intéressant de voir quel type de
choses fait peur à qui quels mécanismes
je sais je dis tout temps le mécanisme
ou mécanique de risques alors un extrait
marne en doute les faux je le dis
mécanique des mécaniques mécanique
mécanique mécanique l'aja mécanique et
une mécanique mécanique l'art des trucs
que je préfère moi c'est quand ça joue
dans le flou de l'image etc à quelque
chose qui est là où qui bouge mais on
voit pas vraiment quoi et le perso au
premier plan n'a pas conscience qu'il ya
ça derrière lui c'est juste la mécanique
éternelle qui marchera tout jamais j'ai
l'impression ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est qu'on n'est pas tous
sensibles aux mêmes choses par exemple y
en a ils ont très très peur genre des
vieilles poupées y en a ils ont vraiment
peur du délire possession démoniaque du
coup je trouve ça trop intéressant
chaque fois de me dire bon quel axe le
réalisateur a pris et comment il va s'y
prendre pour nous faire peur j'ai eu pas
mal de nouvelles choses qui sont
arrivées ces derniers temps il ya des
films d'horreur assez ouf je pense
notamment à hérédité 0 spoil j'en parle
même pas mais c'est génial soit les
persos l'histoire la mise en scène les
mécaniques les fameuses et bref au delà
des films et un truc s'est beaucoup
développé ces des petits courts métrages
d'horreur ou juste des t-shirts de 10 15
20 secondes de vidéo qui bien évidemment
la plupart du temps son fight bon même
si des fois y'a des vidéos creepy on
sait pas trop c'est fake ou pas il y en
a énormément qui sont faites mais qui
sont des fakes incroyable qu'on demande
énormément de travail
bref j'adore ce monde de l'horreur
j'adore découvrir comment des gens s'y
sont pris pour nous faire bien bas dé
quoi il ya vraiment mille manières de
faire bander les gens et donc tout ça
hyper intéressant il est aussi l'une des
manières faire bander les gens et c'est
le sujet de cette vidéo c'est les
petites vidéos que sur internet qui sont
terrifiantes
on est loin d'un court métrage d'un film
c'est des trucs qui dure dix vingt
trente secondes et qui met mega mall
vraiment vous allez frais dira
probablement autant mal qu'après 1
serait de voir si ce n'est plus vraiment
parce que là c'est très visuel
voilà regarder ça bien le soir tard ou
alors le en plein après midi si vraiment
où ça vous fait trop flipper c'est
reparti ça s'est passé il ya un an je
bossais en tant que garde dans un
hôpital la chaise roulante était de
l'autre côté du couloir lors de ma
première patrouille
voilà sur quoi je suis tombé lors ma
deuxième patrouille pas juste ça c'est
badens juste assez bas dont même s'ils
se passe rien
si direct parking ça me fait pas peur et
je veux dire c'est horrible mais ces
réactions elle est drôle ça se voit que
c'est cette up ou alors est bien
vraiment photo mh et il n'est pas vivre
ce gars au moment où on se parle
ok le père de mon ami à une ring et la
femme auraient fini de la tue souvenez
vous voilà sur quoi il est tombé en
regardant les vidéos
hu au non elle n'est pas bien du tout
cette fois non
oh non mais y'a de la maladie mentale la
derrière ça se voit à la peau
[Musique]
elle somme attends attends attends
attends c'est dans y'a rien qui
m'effraie plus que la folie en fait ça
m'effraie au plus profond de mon être là
clairement on a l'impression d'être face
à quelqu'un qui va faire un acte
prémédité quoi elle a un couteau dans la
main on voit qu'elles se posent des
questions qu'elle hésite qu'elle hésite
et qu'elle va franchir le pas et on
dirait vraiment qu'elle veut juste tuer
quelqu'un et c'est prémédité c'est
horrible alors regardez ses yeux au
mondial stop stop stop ça se trouve
c'est fake un essai juste un jeune il a
demandé à sa mère de faire ça pour faire
le buzz sur le net
auquel cas cette femme va très bien et
en plus d'aller très bien c'est une
excellente comédienne
on se rassure comme on peut laissez moi
un ami à moi est sorti prendre l'air et
il a vu cette femme debout sur un toit
au non avec la robe en plus c'est badens
aux oreilles à plusieurs type d'horaire
moi j'ai pas vraiment peur de la
possession d esprit des fantômes et oups
j'ai peur des gens fous en fait c'est
horrible mais j'ai peur de tomber sur
des gens qui ont un problème et deux pas
du tout savoir comment réagir face avait
peut-être de provoquer des réactions
énervé en fait chez eux de part mon
manque de savoir en fait mais par
exemple typiquement là si je sors d'un
truc je tombe face à ça mais je me chie
dessus mais vraiment c'est terrible à la
semaine du beurre à moscou d'être
sérieux au à ses battants ses battants
et un peu cool à la fois il ya un truc
artistique beau ou alors je suis fait
les je suis peul et un homme à portland
s'est fait crever ses pneus et il a
retrouvé cette note sur sa voiture
tu étais tellement facile à trouver marc
tu devrait conduire plus prudemment ce
genre de sociopathes là c'est tellement
bas dans ça ça arrive vraiment à pas
beaucoup de gens mais pas mal de gens
des trucs comme ça de gars qui contact
au téléphone qui dit je sais où tu
habites machin et oui tu sais pas qui
c'est tu seras jamais qui c'est et ça se
trouve c'est quelqu'un de son entourage
ira à ça c'est ça je les ai vus passer
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
ça ce délire là c'est clairement le
délire asiatique de laura georges the
grudge ring et tous ces trucs là c'est
des femmes en robe avec des cheveux
noirs longs qui cachent leur visage et
qui se déplace un peu comme genre d
femme araignée et mec j'ai fait un
[ __ ] de cauchemars pendant des années
tout les mois où il avait une femme
araignée comme ça qui était chez moi et
qui me pourrait après c'était horrible
je crois vraiment laissé des séquelles
juste de the grudge et the ring que j'ai
regardé quand j'avais genre 10 ans et
j'étais beaucoup trop jeune pour
regarder un film comme ça quoi et lui
mbg corps en gros c'est un mec et roches
en 3d et il fait beaucoup de trucs
badauds comme ça il en a fait un
deuxième qui est halal amex et à ses
trucs de famars et la serm je vous jure
j'en ai fait des cauchemars de fou de sa
vidéo flippante d'une porte qui se
claque à répétition dans une morgue il
ya le mot mort du foot tout va bien non
oh
la petite lumière qui clignote c'est un
poil trop cliché pour que ce soit vrai
bien évidemment à la lumière qui
s'éteint et bien évidemment n'y a rien
du tout 100% fake mais franchement
j'admettrai très beau fake merci au
juste le lieu sans la porte qui claque
la lumière qui clignote déjà je me chie
dessus y'a même pas besoin qu'une porte
claque à répétition ouah ça je pense
qu'un dessin aide de camp un mois je
pense s'est clairement inspiré d'une
scène dans eat follows tout ce qu'on
veut il faut l'os vous l'avez cette
scène où il ya un gars très très grand
qui passe une porte vous l'avez en fait
voilà voilà c'est ça les corps difforme
qui sont soit trop grand soin qui se
tiennent bizarre ça me glace au jus
s'cusez moi je fais du fret parfait
c'est vraiment bien fait [ __ ] c'est
beau bien joué mais qu à je suis
n'oubliez pas de regarder les toilettes
autour de vous ça chien match va nous
créer des phobies [ __ ] c'est le rôle
de maître et d'horreur ça normalement
oui à quoi quoi
ah c'est un paresseux [ __ ] mais
attends je me rends compte du potentiel
creepy d'un paresseux c'est terrible
terrifiant reste animal ça s'est
tellement genre la peur que 100% des
humains ont eu c'est vrai ou faux mais
maintenant ça me fait pas dire combien
de fois tu t'es fait avoir par une
chaise ou un porte manteau ou dans le
noir tu as cru voir la silhouette de
quelqu'un et tu t'es tu t'es énormément
chier dessus et en fait pas du tout
pardon j'ai juste été reniées il y aura
pas de come on se regarde c'est moi le
screamer directement des roms alors de
mécanique je suis content parce qu'il ya
une mécanique était vraiment hyper
utilisés et que je trouvais vraiment
chiante c'était l'escrimeur les fameuses
creamer ou d'un coup le niveau audio
baisse il ya un petit moment de blanc et
bas ça crie très fort il ya un truc à
paris c'est vraiment la manière un peu
nul de faire peur tout ça beaucoup plus
cool d'avoir peur à cause d'une ambiance
du comportement au long terme d'un
personnage d'une mécanique qui dure et
pas juste dans un one shot qui arrivent
et qui fait pas et j'avoue je sursaute
très facilement genre dans là c'est un
peu ma phobie même quand je marche dans
la rue et car un marteau piqueur d'un
truc qui s'activent vraiment j'ai peur
j'ai un saut de coeur de ouf
mais ce n'est pas de la peur cool c'est
de la peur juste battu surprend mais
sens tu vois c'est c'est nul voilà voilà
du coup dur non plus créé baril est
passé au dessus de la les escales et que
je dois emprunter pour partir du travail
très malin ton boss c'est un bon moyen
de pousser les gens à rester au taf à
travailler plus mais que moi je monte
c'est marche pas je passe le reste de ma
vie à travailler c'est fini je vende
plus jamais chez moi ta mais il faut
arrêter d'avoir chez vous des endroits
comme ça quoi
faut arrêter c'est terrifiant tous les
trucs qui vont vers le bas et qui amène
dans un endroit on voit rien il faut les
bannir
c'est vraiment arrêté la femme à droite
est morte c'est un exemple de photos
après mort une tradition un peu morbide
du 19e siècle utilisé pour se souvenir à
jamais de nos proches décédés
ah ouais c'est à dire qu'ils ont beau
mais la personne décédée dont la ville
de samson et c'est pour qu'elles soient
hyper bien présente avec ne pourrissent
pas quand il la mettait dans des
postures pour fake et un moment de vie
en fait boire après c'est vrai que la
vision de la mort a beaucoup évolué avec
le temps c'est à dire qu'à l'epoque est
déjà beaucoup plus de gens qui mouraient
est beaucoup plus de gens qui mouraient
chez eux
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un truc
vraiment que je trouve assez tabou la
mort ou le les cadavres en général c'est
marrant comme à l'époque
il y avait on n'avait pas la même vision
de sacs et maintenant je trouve ça
marrant l'évolution pas marrant
intéressant je nourris le démon c'est
quoi cette connerie mais tu vois là si
le gars et shuai fixé que ce qui sort du
trou c'est pas c'est pas rien on colle à
la peau noire avec un masque bouhila et
c'est plutôt genre une femme araignée en
3d a reculé franchement là j'me chie
dessus
il en faut peu on n'était que quatre
dans la voiture c'est une photo qui date
de cinq ans et jeunes remarqué le visage
sur la gauche mais alors ça attention
par aei dolly c'est ça envoie ya
beaucoup beaucoup de photos bas dante ou
c'est juste de l'appareil de lieux où il
ya un délire de reflets de froch
chevrette mamba b ça fait vraiment peur
ici devant ma maison avec c'est pour ça
que j'adore les grandes villes un des
amis c'est parce que dans les endroits
comme ça avec moi je monsieur mais rien
comme c'est terrifiant c'est terrible tu
as länder il peut arriver de n'importe
quel endroit là vous faire il a une mini
maison dans un coin un peu paumé en
normandie et je vous jure
quand j'y vais je suis pas bien à cause
de ça je me dit ah si je peux me faire
attaquer de partout ici un blème n'y a
personne pour m'aider mais après je suis
stressé de la vie eh bien écoutez iphone
cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plus d une
autre manière d'approcher un peu le
thème de l'horreur 15ème que j'adore et
j'aimerais à tout prix un jour vous
proposer un court métrage d'horreur
durera peut-être ça en fin d'année sur
la chaîne youtube je veux trop essayé
moi aussi de faire un truc flippant
autrement qu'en racontant de l'histoire
flippante bien évidemment moi j'espère
que ça vous a plu
je suis désolé s'il y en a qui kiffe pas
regarder des trucs d'horreur vous n'avez
pas dû trop vous amuser en tout cas j'ai
bien kiffé je trouve ça vraiment coup je
demande un peu ce qui va sortir comme un
film d'horreur dans le futur j'attends
aussi beaucoup en terme de jeu le
outlast en coop
enfin moyen atlas en coop qui va sortir
et aussi j'aimerais bien qu'hideo kojima
refasse un [ __ ] de piticco halal là
franchement il y avait des bêtes de
mécanique d'un jeu et c'était trop bien
fait j'aimerais revoir ça que moi en
tout cas pas sur d'excellents sept jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]